[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are gonna be talking about
the importance of entrepreneurship we
have Ryan Micheletti joining us thank
you for coming on the show thank you
it's a pleasure and we have you four
years behind you at as the director of
global operations at founder Institute
which is a pre seed accelerator for
company startup companies that have
meaning that of purpose that are driven
we also have six years at as the founder
of vet tech right correct and with the
veteran founder initiative so we'll be
unpacking that as well
I really we have we've a cool
partnership that we've struck up as well
the simulation fellowship so this is
gonna be really exciting catalyzing more
scientists to become entrepreneurs and
also will be unpacking that as we go
through let's just start talking about
this from a perspective of you I'd like
to hear more from you about how you got
started with being so passionate about
entrepreneurship passionate about
veterans teachers about that sure yeah
so I guess my entrepreneurial journey
really started when I was in the
military so I did six years in the
reserves in the California Guard and I
noticed that there was a big correlation
between military service and
entrepreneurship things like leadership
the ability to execute right the ability
to overcome like very very large odds
right and really kind of stretch sure at
what we call adversity muscle and so you
know being born and raised here in
Silicon Valley I knew that the frontline
of innovation was here and so I decided
to jump headfirst into entrepreneurship
and so I co-founded vet tech which is
the nation's premier startup accelerator
for military
we help veterans all over the the US and
even internationally if they're there
stationed abroad work with Silicon
Valley Advisors investors and plug them
into to our local Silicon Valley Network
as well as our international network of
resources using the the founder
Institute as one of our engines and what
I said adversity muscle they're really
strong at being able to to execute to be
able to find that vision and bring it
forth into the world and that's really
good that you're making that happen with
Silicon Valley ecosystem yeah yeah if
you look at you know what makes a great
entrepreneur right you they have to be
smart they have to be open right to to
new ideas but you know if you ask any
great investor go up and down Sand Hill
Road they'll tell you that the most
important thing is the founder
themselves right the idea is very
important but you can't take a great
idea with a bad founder and make it
successful right you can take a good
idea with a great founder and that could
be a massive success and so that's why
at founder Institute where the founder
Institute we focus on the individual
first right cuz we know that great
companies start with great people yeah
in the network's gotten massive it's a
almost 200 cities 3,000 over 3,000
companies over 10,000 Mentors
wow that's a huge network and especially
being able to plug veterans into that as
well and to the founder Institute
network so then so then as you
transitioned over to from service to
entrepreneurship and helping
entrepreneurs you were you know you're
discussing the importance of the of the
founder themselves what else have you
found to be some of these really
important because we we sometimes on the
show we like to say that
entrepreneurship is the best thing
you'll ever do that it's drives a lot of
meaning to people's lives so like what
do you what do you think about about
that yeah well so I think their
entrepreneurship is is of growing topic
I mean we're in 200 cities and so what's
really interesting is seeing the the
local dynamics so whether it's you're
launching companies in Kabul Afghanistan
or South Paulo Brazil right every
markets a little bit different
but there's common threads and I always
like to make a distinction that there's
a difference between a founder and an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is someone
that like realigns resources to create
economic value a founder is a creator a
founder is someone that's doing
something that's like okay here's my
here's my legend here's the thing that
I'm gonna do to build my legacy and so
you've heard that distinction before
that's interesting one yeah yeah I mean
you know I would go as far as to say
that you know if you it's really about
your life purpose and what you what you
want to achieve and I think that you
know I've seen I've worked with plenty
of entrepreneurs all around the world
and the ones that tend to succeed have
really found that meaning like why are
they here what are they supposed to do
and usually it's tied towards like some
greater purpose right and that's another
kind of thread that you see with a lot
of military veterans right they they
kind of passed what we called the virtue
test which is you know countries at war
I'm gonna volunteer my time in my
service and potentially risk my life to
do something and contribute something
greater to myself so right right right
off the bat we're working with a group
of people that kind of get that right
and so there's so I you know I do think
there's a big difference between like
the founder and in an entrepreneur and I
would go as far as to say that you know
really takes someone to have deep
introspection to figure out what it is
that they want to do yep in the world
yeah it's it's easier to take people
that already have the mentality of
building something bigger than
themselves or serving a goal that's
bigger than themselves then it is to try
and train that into into someone so
that's a huge advantage with working
with with veterans okay so you so
everything from Sao Paulo to Kabul right
that's crazy
there's like big distinctions in those
entrepreneurial ecosystems they're
totally different places
what have you noticed is going on around
the world in the different
entrepreneurial ecosystems as they sort
of flourish because there's a lot of
things that hold people back like women
getting involved in the entrepreneurial
space are in the founder space yeah yes
oh yeah teach us about that so well
there's there's a lot to that right and
a lot of it depends on like how robust
is the ecosystem what are some of the
socio-economic what's that climate look
like I think ultimately like you know
regardless I've seen this across like
almost every city like and it goes back
to starting with the individual person
sometimes people have limiting beliefs
about themselves that keep them from
taking the steps and doing the things
that that can help get them to achieve
something great and I think you know as
you said like entrepreneurship can be
one of the greatest things that a person
does it's also one of the hardest things
a person can do so there's an you know
I'm looking here right right so dreams
don't work unless you do well so you
know at founder Institute we basically
provide like the global network and the
framework to build something incredible
right and and that's what we focus on
we're looking for like the the a player
type entrepreneurs who are looking to
build something very meaningful for
themselves but also also the the world
at large right we're increasing becoming
that this this global network and so
whether it's Kabul right or South Paulo
I think part of it is like starting with
the core of the founder but then like
giving them the opportunity to succeed
right we can't build the company for
them they actually have to be the one to
do the work and go through the process
and we give them all the resources they
need but if they don't have that inner
strength and that that inner vision of
like I'm gonna go and do this one thing
to conquer the world or build their
legacy then you know they tend to be
less committed right they're they're
less committed to themselves and their
goals and so that that tends to be like
when you see a founder fail the number
one cause of failure and the
Entrepreneurship community is that
founder just gives up yeah they're
giving up they just literally like I
mean it's not they ran out of money it's
like you can operate your company on no
money
it just means you can't hire
so you have to just have that tenacity
yes and so that's one thing that working
with the veteran community over the last
six years they just have that tenacity
right it's like run through this brick
wall sure sure I'll do it backwards
right and it's so there's a lot of
there's a lot of things to be said about
you know working with someone who has
that like you know really strong like
passion and desire and I think if you if
you take someone who who has like a
really strong purpose they'll have
they'll they'll find the inner strength
to like succeed right because they're
doing something they're passionate about
they'll they'll figure it out right but
if they're if they kind of are like hey
you know what would be great is like
another like food delivery company that
I don't really care about but it sounds
like cool and entrepreneurships kind of
cool so I'm just gonna try it I mean
like zero chance of success right it
really like I would I would say that
there's almost like a divine purpose
behind the individual I'm behind on what
they're doing just right so if you're in
it to just make money first of all like
you're in the wrong industry like go
become an investment banker or something
and right like you know entrepreneurship
is not about just making money right
it's about it's about achieving that
purpose yep there's totally a divinity
behind it and I really did once you get
set moving forward with that goal that
purpose that meat whatever is driving
you meaning with building something into
the world the only thing that holds you
back is yourself and I like how you
brought that up that's so that's that's
almost always always why people quit and
then you mentioned earlier the FI
founder its to provides so much in terms
of resources so like what does it look
like for a company to for someone to Co
go with an idea where do they have to be
at with their idea and then what
resources they get how many months they
have yeah sure so fi takes the approach
that were there to help the company
throughout its entire lifecycle right
our core program and we have multiple
like kind of layers to this but our core
program is a 14 week per
that's geared towards entrepreneurs and
people who have ideas and they want to
become entrepreneurs so you know at the
earliest stage you could be you could
just have an idea right and you you go
through our process and we can't
validate that through our mentors and
through it through our curriculum on the
the later stage side of it you could
have a team that's incorporated and you
just haven't raised funding yet I
usually tell you know founders the core
program is focused on what we call
precede I mean you haven't raised a seed
round so you haven't raised you know
you've raised more than $250,000 like
you know there's other programs and
things that that we could help you with
but you know the core program is focused
on what we call that launch phase right
ideation just sort of early company yeah
so we put founders through the gauntlet
I always joke around I call it Navy SEAL
training for entrepreneurs yeah yeah
some of our founders like you know post
on Twitter and Facebook it's like Hunger
Games for entrepreneurs and you know
there's a little bit of that right
because we know that starting companies
very hard so we make the program very
challenging but also very practical
right this isn't you know you're not
going to school to learn about
entrepreneurship these aren't case
studies this isn't you know
entrepreneurship school this is I'm
launching my company right right now
right now and you've seen it cuz you're
a mentor right so you've seen a couple
of the sessions and how it works and you
know it's very transformative like
taking someone who has just this kind of
idea right then they start the program
and they go through these 14 weeks where
they're working with mentors they're
working with their fellow founders
they're going through and doing like you
know it's about 20 to 25 hours of work a
week and then you know at that at the
end after the 14 weeks at our demo day
it's like a huge huge transformation and
there's something to be said about
someone just like coming up with an idea
literally doing all the work to pull
that out into this real world and create
something right I mean that's modern day
alchemy right yeah yeah there's there's
definitely something so gorgeous about
the actual process of going from week
zero to week fourteen and just seeing
what happens in this pre-staged period
of the idea of the
burst into reality I love that that that
that a lot of I can totally sense that
that is what is a lot of the feel for
you and the fuel for a day on the feel
for the FI team because it is go you
almost you it's like there's some sort
of state that is you can see in the soul
of the person as they're unleashing
something bigger than themselves into
the world it's it's nuts and and you can
tell sort of you know almost right away
right who's who's in it for for you know
to because they just have to launch this
coming it's like part of who they are
versus someone that's like they see an
opportunity and they're kind of half in
and half out and so our program
basically just like Queens to be honest
like I mean you shouldn't be starting a
company begin with you're gonna waste
tons of time and money I mean I've had
founders in my program who've spent
$200,000 building an app like week three
of the program they came out to me and
said Ryan I've made a discovery
I built the wrong app and so $200,000 in
two years of their life later yeah you
know they could if they had just taken
the program through three weeks into it
they would have figured that out right
and so so and we I would also say that
you know aside from like those stories
of people like wasting a lot of time and
money even the founders that don't make
it through our program right I think
that's a success and we we constantly
get great letters from our founders
saying I learned so much thank you this
was amazing because we're essentially
saving them a lot of time correct we're
condensing the entrepreneur experience
where you know you'll get so much
further ahead by just starting off into
our program when you launch your company
then if you were to kind of like you
know meander around the ecosystem maybe
do a little of this like you know where
do you begin as an entrepreneur you you
are already a guide that helps with the
hike up the mountain versus just having
a roam around the base until you find
like an ideal route up and like it takes
a long time try to do that I remember
when I was first really going heavier
into pursuing entrepreneurship in the
your collegiate days that it was just so
hard I was constantly trying to be like
where's the mentors where's the mentors
I really need people that can guide that
hike up the mountain and then when I
came out here when I was 19 I
immediately started looking for those
people and only recently after like the
six hard years of treacherous suffering
through the process of entrepreneurship
do you really find powerful mentors that
are willing to invest in you and this is
just this is this is almost moving me to
tears because I I don't think I've quite
fully thought about things in the way
that you're describing them with the
person manifesting an idea out of their
soul that then goes in and and they and
they continue pouring their energy and
and other people sometimes do to make
impact on the world that that sort of
that is a huge essence of existence and
a driver right and I love how yeah the
process totally weeds out the people
that are incompatible with
entrepreneurship or at least that idea
might have been incompatible and then
they fare might find a different one now
you know when I've come in and done
mentorship with that fie there's all
different types of you know periods from
the actual ideation to market research
to actually doing research on on your
product and service that you're actually
building starting that that process of
actually building it there's so many
phases so you know it's like a week at a
time is a different phase yeah exactly
and everything builds on top of each
other so we we basically put the
founders on Rails and say just do the
work like get it done and you'll be
you'll be very happy at the end because
that every week builds on top of the
last week's work right and that's that's
really important there's a lot of so
once you graduate the program there's a
lot of post program support that we
provide you know everything from an
entire program geared towards
fundraising so we help founders close
their seed round in fact one of our
Silicon Valley grads who I think is
coming on the show a little bit later
today Alexi he just closed a 1.5 million
dollar round he's like one of the world
quantum computing experts and that's you
know he did that through our founder lab
program so so just so almost like
graduating fi is just like making it
through boot camp right it's like you
alright you made it you're an F I've
company now and now you have this entire
global network of support to help you
right so we do a lot of follow-on
programs a lot of like office hours with
Silicon Valley we can connect you to
eleven thousand mentors around the world
and we're actually just starting two
vertical eyes their programs as well so
we recently launched a program a
blockchain program in Toronto with the
co-founder of aetherium yes a new Diorio
yeah and the idea is that block you know
Toronto's a centre of like blockchain
entrepreneurs like there's so many it's
it's because it's a you know financial
hub but so so Anthony came aboard loved
our mission it was like let's create you
know a movement let's let's launch a lot
of blockchain companies to try and like
create more entrepreneurs in the space
and so so we launched it in partnership
with them it actually starts on Monday
this coming week and so that's gonna be
very exciting where we have about 25
blockchain entrepreneurs in the program
and 25 regular founders in the program
so it'll be interesting to see like the
dynamic of it so we've got some top
mentors from around the world who are
doing office hours with them and great
yeah so so we're starting to vertical
eyes a little bit weird got a couple
other programs we've got an AI program
launching in Pittsburgh we've got a food
tech program in Helsinki Finland and so
what I'm seeing now is it's at least in
these like different regions of the
world is there's like some
specialization happening yes right and
and it's important because that gives
you sort of a nation so we're basically
following that trend and in these
regions where there's just a y
concentration of these vertical
entrepreneurs we're looking at doing
special verticals for them and that
creates a network effect in those areas
so people that are very interested in
the future food get to hang out with
other people interested in future food
and then collaborate and execute same
thing with AI and blockchain that they
get to yeah also we have a lot to just
discuss in general about and about a
network theory and like mathematical
sociology cybron
we have a lot to talk about that because
there's a lot that we're doing that
relates to that that we should
definitely talk about a bit after this
because it's a huge part of our collab
with the simulation fellowship because I
I don't I - I feel a hugely long term
vision with this where it is all of the
different diverse leadership that we've
had on the program plus all of the
people that are on the brink of wanting
to become entrepreneurs they're doing
9:00 to 5:00 but they're doing side
hustles or they are anywhere from the
idea stage on a sheet of paper all the
way to having an actual product or
service that they've started to build
and they're now looking for the next
steps and stuff that that those that all
of the people that I just listed there
they can be categorized with with tags
as in like neuroscience or AI or block
chain or geopolitics emotional
intelligence all these different tags
and then from there it makes it easier
to build out this sort of global
ecosystem of mentors based on fields of
interest that's the whole this is those
whole network Theory conversation and so
we're writing a lot and working a lot on
that and I think that's that's a huge
part of this sort of longer-term vision
with things like this partnership so so
with with the partnership itself you
know I really want you to speak on the
CERN more because you are way more
indeed deep into facility with
catalyzing entrepreneurship into the
world just from just from what what I
care a lot about it's like they're like
they're right at the pull-up bar they're
right there at the pull-up bar they're
almost done with their you know their
chin up or the polar right and and you
know this is like that little tiny like
a cyst that gets them to complete the
Entrepreneurship pull up and that's a
lot of what you know what we're hoping
to do with this program especially for
the sciences robot assist biotech
neuroscience even blockchain and
cryptocurrency anything to do with
emotions
or or energy or and you bring up a
really great point and I think it's it's
really important to kind of frame this
around like the core of Fi and why it
even exists you know if you look at all
the problems that are plaguing humanity
right you could just go down to like you
know an entire list look at the 17 UN
sustainable goals right it's like you
know and world hunger right and disease
like Oh that'd be great if someone could
could do that right and so we believe
that the only way to solve some of these
the biggest problems facing humanity is
to empower smart and talented people to
build technologies and companies that
can directly address it right and so so
that's actually why we started founder
Institute in the beginning right it's
like let's do this on a global scale
let's go into these cities let's find
great entrepreneurs great people let's
wake them up and say hey listen your
purpose is to create and to do something
meaningful like why don't you take all
the skills that you've learned over over
your lifetime and create something
meaningful and so that ties into an
initiative that we launched earlier this
year called Fi for good yeah and and the
idea is is really that you know there's
a lot of stupid companies out there so a
lot of stupid like the world doesn't
need another social network the world
doesn't need another food delivery
company you know what the world needs it
needs to cure cancer right it needs to
stop polluting the oceans right it
there's all these things that are kind
of obvious right that that we in the
position that we're in being being
global and in 200 cities we feel an
obligation like okay let's let's find
these people these subject matter
experts these scientists these you know
you know experts in the field and let's
give them the tools and the network and
the resources to build something that
can actually impact humanity as a whole
and so that was the the concept of Fi
for good and also the catalyst of the
fellowship the simulation fellowship
that we're launching which is you know a
lot of the people who subscribe and are
part of the the simulation series
community are these subject matter
experts and it's really a rally cry
- to those people like the time is now
you cannot we cannot wait any any
further like the if we're gonna solve
these problems like we're kind of
running out of time right the world's
not getting smaller so if you're looking
for a sign like this is the sign go
start a company go use the things that
you've built up over over the last you
know several decades of your life and
and do something that can really change
the world
love it you you're nailing it the links
in the bio fi dot code for its last
joint for its life simulation and you
can go look at the simulation fellowship
again a call to action for people that
are right there complete wanting to
solve some of the world's biggest
challenges fi for good it's a huge push
in this direction just focus on the big
challenging issues the United Nations
sustainable development goals are a
really great like pillar system to be
like yeah like these are the really
important ones and there's there's a lot
that the unknown unknowns that we don't
quite know yet that we can also help a
lot of mitigation of existential risk
there's a lot of things that that need
to that need to come into play thanks to
things don't reproduce so that that was
a really those really well said other
thoughts about about the fellowship
before we transition to yeah so I mean
essentially what the fellowship is it's
it's a scholarship to the program right
so if you're like a leading scientist or
an expert or you're just doing something
that's impactful right like in that that
can actually like you'll be on like the
cutting edge of technology we call
frontier technologies you know we'll let
you in the program for free because our
goal is to just help you build a great
company right so you know it costs about
fifteen hundred bucks depending on where
you are in the world to take the program
and that's for for a couple different
reasons but basically like fi bootstrap
we never took investment capital because
as soon as you take investment capital
at your mission changes it's no longer
we're gonna change the world that's now
we're gonna make a return for our
investors
you know so so just from a strategy
standpoint we're like okay well we're
gonna have to charge with the program so
what we do those we create these
fellowships we have a global female
founder initiative we have a female
fellowship we have a national veteran
founder initiative which we'll talk
about in a second and now we have this
simulation fellowship right for these
frontier technologists to to take their
skills and build companies and so
essentially you get to join the program
for free you can apply for free and and
we'll let you in and then you throughout
the program we help you launch your
company once you graduate the core
program will help you fundraise through
our founder lab program well introduce
you to corporate partners and customers
and then ideally that in a perfect
scenario they'll be sitting right here
in this chair after they've launched
their company having an interview with
you talking about how you know what
they're doing and how it's changing the
world exactly the simulation fellowships
is a scholarship that this is a $1500 14
week beautiful process that you can go
through to actualize your idea into the
world with an ecosystem of of resources
and people that are just amazing at the
top of the world and so this is a huge
gift from founder Institute to be able
to open up a fellowship a scholarship
for simulation for these cutting-edge
scientists that are really wanting to
solve some of humanity's biggest
challenges so there's a cohort that
starts in December in Silicon Valley so
there's still a process a period of six
weeks six weeks left
but applications are due in December and
in December yes the applications are due
in December and then the program starts
second week in January so if you go to
fi dot CEO and you you look for a
Silicon Valley program you'll see all
the information there you'd also just
email me Ryan at fi dot co you know tell
him to tell me about what you're doing
and I'll make sure that you get
connected to the right people and I
think yeah I think like we're starting
with Silicon Valley San Francisco kind
of Bay Area but we want to scale this
out nationally absolutely yeah well see
we have like we said earlier with this
is explain
the network it's it's a nuts that we
have so many other diverse leadership
across the world that can plug into a
scholarship in the different city hubs
that are going on and we just need to
look at the data better regionally do
better data sites and better data
visualization around the network theory
topics or LC ology and demographics and
how people are evolving and how they're
connecting and how we can just have a
better visualization of that so we
actually have a lot of that data
everyone who joins the program has to
take in what we call an entrepreneur DNA
test and this is a psychometric test it
takes about an hour to complete it's
based on the the Big Five personality
traits and I think today we'll work with
Jordan Peterson on that right mm-hmm
and so the the idea is that is that we
basically have the the scores and the
psychometric tests of people from like
all over the world and so we can make
like you know determinations of like
personality traits and just kind of
entrepreneurship it's more about
entrepreneurship in general right what
are the core traits of entrepreneurs in
like India versus Mexico versus Canada
and it's just it's so we quantify a lot
of that the information that we have
which is really fascinating and it's so
cool yeah yeah well we'll eventually
publish it we're still you know we're in
the phase where we're just like can
continue to gather gather gather yeah
but eventually we'll we'll publish our
findings and hopefully that'll make a
big impact openness conscientiousness
extraversion agreeableness and
neuroticism and fluid intelligence is a
good one which is essentially your
ability to learn things quickly it's a
little bit different than just
intelligence so if you learn things
quickly right so it turns out if you're
smart and you learn quickly and you're
also open to new ideas you can iterate
and you can start creating something new
faster and that's that's one that's
those are kind of a Tuesday together and
I guess like once one final point you
run yeah go ahead one one final point on
the the simulation fellowship is it
essentially we're giving like you know
people who are experts in their field
may not have ever been an entrepreneur
so there's this there's this very nice
complementary skill set where you have
the raw talent as a scientist as an
expert in technology and now we're
giving you the business acumen in the
business skills and I've seen great
founders you know start a start amazing
companies in the program because of that
pairing of the skill set yep
let's and I just want to also mention
that you know at Indy bio which is the
largest seed stage biotech accelerator
where I mentor as well and that we have
a partnership going on with them it's
very similar in just the sense that they
have a tremendous amount of scientists
that are doing this pull up this gin up
and that they just need that little bit
of entrepreneurial kick so that their
idea goes from the lab into reality and
so this is this is a gorgeous process
and I loved how we were talking about it
earlier is this unleashing of a soul
purpose into the world the idea that
transcends the individual I love that
yeah yeah okay let's talk about the
veteran founder initiative because vet
tech rocks and I got the chance to meet
a couple of the veterans that are
building amazing companies and like you
said they have this adversity muscles
that's been trained over time and
they're they're solving the big problems
they're doing the fi4 good the big scale
problems so teach us about it yeah so
you know one of our mutual friends
Richard browning who literally invented
the Ironman suit it's it's like
real-life jet suit that he was a marine
in the the British Navy so he was a
Royal Marine and he basically kind of
through his process and through some of
the things he learned from his father
who was started the original original
jet suit basically created this amazing
technology that you know over I think
he's head of like over like 30 different
countries flights in different countries
and we we did a quick filming of that
down at the San Carlos Airport so that's
just one example right and there's
there's a lot of other examples like you
know veterans kind of get put into a box
a little bit but like oh they're gonna
do like you know missile defense or
they're gonna do cybersecurity and
that's true right
but like I've seen veterans start in
fact I met with with one yesterday
that's doing agricultural technologies
right and so things that that are kind
of outside of the military and the kind
of like rust kind of stuff that happens
while you're in the military they're
building technologies that you you might
not initially think and so through my
work at vet tech I discovered kind of
the correlation with with veterans and
you know every year about two hundred
thousand veterans or military personnel
leave the military right and 25% of them
aspire to be an entrepreneur and we feel
that like a percentage of those that 25%
want to be technology entrepreneurs the
problem is that there's not a lot of
resources for serious like expert
resources for for veterans that want to
launch like a Silicon Valley tech
company right
and so we aim to blame to bridge that
gap so the mission of the veteran
founder initiative is really to unite
the veteran entrepreneurship ecosystem
to help launch a hundred veteran LED
technology companies every year so so
we're starting off with what we call the
the veteran founder initiative
fellowship we've partnered with Patriot
boot camp to launch the Patriot boot
camp fellowship which allows people
within the Patriot boot camp community
and really any veteran who applies for
it to take our program for free again
helping to to you know help this like
underrepresented community in in
entrepreneurship help them launch more
companies help them kind of get to the
forefront of building something great so
so the veteran founder initiative is
really starting off with this fellowship
but there's a whole slew of resources
that we've that we've been able to
curate to help them through through the
entire like I guess you know startup
phase of their company right so we we
have a partnership not only with Patriot
boot camp but we're working with
organizations like the bunker labs which
is a really great like meetup
organization that adds like a layer of
local community for for these founders
so essentially what we want to do is
create what we call the veteran founder
roadmap you know as you leave the
military where do you start how do you
how do you go from you know being a
staff sergeant in the military to being
a
technology entrepreneur and there's a
lot that has to happen you you probably
already have the core of what it takes
but we want to make sure that you know
whether it's like learning to code or
just like starting to learn about
entrepreneurship self getting the basic
skills and then essentially coming to
founder Institute to launch the company
and then we can help them fundraise we
give through through founder lab we can
help them connect to our corporate
partners and eventually join that tact
which is the accelerator part
partnership that we have so we basically
created this like this spectrum of
resources to help veterans succeed yeah
and it's so we can we can send veterans
through like this process we were
talking about this prior to the show of
accelerating their success with
entrepreneurship having them manifest
those ideas into the world so veteran
founder initiative and then vet tech so
you know you provide a scholarship
through that fie ecosystem through the
founder initiative and then funnel into
the accelerator portion where they can
get seed stage funding Series A and move
on through executing the idea absolutely
and again I just I'm very blessed with
that because to know you working on that
because you know we've first hand sat
next you know people that have come back
from serving that have that have trauma
that needs to be integrated and then
they have really profound experiences
meditative psychedelic driven however
the the integration happened where
they're literally themselves again
they're you know they're fully
integrated there and it's moved me to
tears and and I think a process like
immediately after that they're just how
do I serve again like in terms of how do
I bring something forth into the world
my soul my my mission my idea how do I
bring that forth and so I love that
you're building this yeah and and just
on that note to I mean there's there's
something to be said about a person who
has seen the darkness in humanity right
and then they come back and they
Costanza say you know what we need to
change something needs to be different
right and then doing something still
like bringing that light within
themselves and like launching something
that can actually affect that change and
so I think that that's really important
sometimes you have to confront that
darkness first and like you know really
really take a good look at and say okay
how do how do we get through this how do
it how do we you know build something or
create something that kid that can
actually make it make a difference yeah
the u n-- quote about the roots having
to reach down to hell before the leaps
can reach up to heaven yeah yeah that's
a good one
Ryan a couple quick questions on the way
out we typically ask him on the show I
want to hear your thoughts about them
what do you think about us being alone
in the cosmos do you think we're alone I
don't think we're alone I think you know
the universe is truly infinite then
there's truly infinite possibilities I
think it kind of depends on what you
mean if you're alone but you know
literally if it's infinite then there
then there's infinite variations of not
only this dimension but of other species
and beings and things out there yeah
lots of unknowns so much do you if
that's you know if that's the case in
this in if this in an infinite universe
then what about simulation theory do you
think we're in a simulation we'll see in
a couple years I don't I don't
necessarily think we're in a simulation
maybe we're in a reflection of like one
reflection of reality right because if
we're if there's multiple dimensions
happening concurrently I think that
maybe like this the simulation is not
that this is just pretend right which I
think people thought ematic Lee think is
like that's what the simulation means
it's but we are just one reflection of
many realities so would that be then the
way that you're perceiving the world is
through your seeing that the reflection
of the way you're seeing the world and
then you have your own sort of mirror
that you're looking through and seeing
the world through it's that kind of
essentially yeah okay okay
Allen always gets really interesting
diverse answers and then what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world I think the most beautiful thing
in the world is is helping someone who
is not not just in need but they're like
in the depths of Hell themselves they're
in the darkness right and being able to
I kind of reach your hand down and pull
them out into the light I think that's
the most beautiful thing in the world
that's that's pure there to your
humanity that's pure transmutation
that's so gorgeous I love it and that's
a really profound feeling you know I
just I felt a lot when you said that
that yeah I love that that's a good
answer on huh yeah I love that one
that's a good one and we have to figure
out the strategies that help bring the
hand down right help across all
different types of people across the
world
what are those helping hands yeah a lot
of the SDGs and other things other
things like that help out Wow the
importance of entrepreneurship there's a
lot of unpacking about Fi and about
getting people started with unleashing
their idea and their soul getting them
catalyzed through your 14 week process
also through fellowships that you have
going on like for veterans for
simulation folks so there's a lot that
we unpacked and that was a great show
thank you for joining us absolutely
anytime super fun yeah thank you I'm
looking I'm looking forward to building
this out and maximizing potential these
ideas into the world yeah do it let's
make it happen
we're almost there yeah yeah exactly
exactly thank you everybody for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it give us a
comment below let us know your thoughts
and some of your thoughts on the episode
we'd love to hear from you also the
links in the bio for for vet tech for
that a veteran founder initiative also
the links in the bio for the simulation
fellowship go and take the risk go and
do it let's build the future together
and Ron thank you for producing and
directing much appreciated much love and
Ryan thank you for coming on the show we
appreciate it
peace much love everyone